I'm westie I'm a seasoned battlefield
pyre and it's fallen to me to take these
for battlefield one novices from
corporals two generals whoa I've got
this guy Mike and sniper over here get
him getting with you so let's go let's
go around behind him who AM L just shot
welcome to battlefield Academy
alright guys welcome to Battlefield
Academy you all know why you're here
you're not very good at battlefield and
you need to get better
oh no oh my god this is all go badly
there's a tank obviously don't badly
come on hey the shop that is so he'll
just I know hey guys I need one more
kill kill him yeah one point one point
let's go shoot yes that went
surprisingly well we did okay I came
bottom in the scoreboard which is to be
expected i imagined mayhem drama action
it was if it was it was a great
experience actually wasn't as horrific
as i thought it might be highlight
though has to be that kind of fight at F
because i was askin aids going on it was
chaotic kills crazies everything he come
to expect from battlefield so wished he
has been really good although I kind of
imagined him being a sterner I just hope
he does something be too harsh on me and
so I think he'll be there mean when I
make mistakes
that's right next to it I'm a horse of
slipstream in it with the assault kit
you've got a submachine gun it's the
best thing you can do with those is just
literally hold down the trigger and keep
firing
doesn't need a lotta lessons
let's get effort there so what you could
do here is like if you could get the
spotting flare out and then like this in
three on the keyboard and then just fire
up on yet I've got my flash whoa they're
all on fire over there so if you throw
bandages you just have to tap Q in it
for a band Oh cute so learning is fun
well I was really happy in general I saw
some big improvements in infantry play
that's what we kind of focused on in
that first game 22 damage 44 yeah it's
down we work better as a squad we were
communicating a lot more shouting at
each other whatever the communication is
it's just sometimes important to tell
people there's loads of them at sea you
know man we won the match we communicate
effectively we all kind of coalesced to
the same goal someone fell down the oven
put them up and you can just see how a
little bit of a knowledge a bit of steel
and a lot of communication can really
help to make us a better battle squad
but all the list of like that all focus
we all going from one place to another
sees but dump one class we know what
they're doing next fall together that's
great we worked so much better as a team
we were sticking together we're giving
each other ammo health as being able to
pick up some really nice shops which I
was really happy where there was this
one section where I was like what what's
going on it's kicking up kills all over
the place oh my god that was a shot in
the first game we're a bit like I guess
I should go over here and I guess
attacked it would be to run towards this
building but but now I'm like in
partially gonna know the map but also
because I know the best way to attack
certain points because of wes is
teaching so yeah definitely
you use third person to line up your
shot and then switch to first person
when you're about to shoot
whoa Phillip Phillip
you could just literally right past your
teammates and then you can just drop
health and ammo straightaway paper girl
from the side
I'm really impressed with with what
they've achieved so far we're working
really really well as a squad together
and that's probably the most important
thing regardless of what their skill
level is being able to work with someone
else is the most important thing because
if you're talking to somebody maybe they
can help you with something that you're
not not not that good at and in
battlefield that is so important because
you've got a defined role your friends
got a different define role if you work
together most of the time you can
achieve the goal that you want I think
come that live stream I don't think
we're going to have a problem we're
coming up against public players and yes
there's some really good players out
there but we've got the squad play
nailed down that they've all got their
roles they all know what they're
supposed to do as long as we work as a
team the public just don't stand a
chance I think they'll be absolutely
fine when they come to the live stream
play it first with EA access